الجنرال الابيض صديقه روسيا الوفي الشتاء
اي تاخر في وصوله سيؤجلوا رهن موسكو
والشتاء وشرق اوروبا حتى الان لم يترك له
الاحتباس الحراري الا الاسم وكما يتحضر
الغرب تتحضر روسيا وشمالا كانت الوجهه حيث
لا يتخلف الصقيع ولا يغيب الممر البحري
الشماليه مسار يربط بين الاطلسي والهداء
مختصرا يربط اسيا واوروبا وامريكا التوضيح
سفينه اتبحروا من مياه شنغهاي الاكبر في
العالم الى ميناء روتردام تقطع مسافه اقل
باربعه الاف كيلو متر من المسار التقليدي
الفريق الكبير يغري شركات الشحن لكن هناك
عائقا واحد وهو جليد العيب ان المسار متاح
صيفا فقط وكان هذا قبل اشتداد الاحتباس
الحراري وذوبان الجديد
وهنا هنا تظهر كاسح والجليد الحديثه وتظهر
موسكو ايضا لتكريس التفوق ابي كاسحه جليدا
جديده تعمل بالطاقه النوويه البلد الوحيد
الذي لديه هذا النوع من الكاسحات قطعه
اخرى تنضموا لاصلها الذي يقتربوا من
الستين سفينه والجديد انها قادره على
ازاحه جلدنا ان يصل سمكه الى مترين اوروبا
تحضرون الصناعه لا مشكله سنتوجه لاسيا
وهكذا استراتيجيه روسيا من هكذا حلول
الصين مثالا تحتاجه الطاقه الروسيه
وشركاتها لم ترفض مصاريف شحن منخفضه ولهذا
ادمج الطريق الشماليه ضمن مشروع الحزام
الحزام والطريق والتفوق الروسي سبقه حضور
عسكري في القطب الشمالي ايضا شيدت قبل
سنوات اول قاعده عسكريه دائمه مدينه صغيره
ومستقله ثمون مره كل عامين والهدف الصريح
حمايه الحركه التجاريه القطبيه بحسب ما
تقول الدفاع الروسيه
في ذا فويس